and logan gilbert
taking the mountain looking to make his
18th start on the year of five and five
record 5-1-6 era
oh that is blasted to deep left center
field back goes more and it's going to
be over his head and whit
will be at second base with nobody out
there goes wit to third and he'll make
it without a throw that's right that's
his 38 stolen base of the year
and his
157th in his career so he breaks the tie
with johnny damon he is ninth all-time
in royals history that's right he knows
opponents are six for six and steals off
of this young man right here so the
royals with a golden opportunity to take
the early lead
back through the middle and into center
field
so the royals add to that
impressive number hitting with runners
in scoring position mom can breathe for
another 20 minutes
and the royals have a one-nothing lead
in the first inning now chris bubich
will make his 15th start this year for
the royals his record
is four and six with a 4.9 for era
there you go extra bases for jp hard out
of the box
and easy double as ben intended he gets
it back in that's the start the mariners
were looking for breaks in oh for eight
that's his 28th double bass is loaded
and there's a bases loaded walk to tie
the ball game and here is designated
hitter luis terence kobich having a
rough time a couple of walks he's given
up two hits
one out base is loaded 1-1 game
there you go the other way down the line
that's going to stay fair
bounces off the wall stays in play
hanukkah scores france scores the hold
toro at third luis duran's lt check it
in and the mariners have a 3-1 lead in
the first
faces
it's up there with nobody out bases
filled again
down goes seeger so bubbage with another
money pitch with the bases loaded but
can he get the next two batters
change up strikes him out back to back
strikeouts with a changeup both with the
bases loaded and there are two down and
the count is three and one on terence
now the wine to ban the three one pitch
to terence and it's up and in for ball
ford another bases loaded walk given up
by boobage
that will score j.p crawford from third
and the mariners now lead the royals
four to one
one run in and the bases are still
loaded tom murphy walked his first time
up
nice hit left field
and a stop sign for ty france
as hanukkah scores on the rbi single by
tom murphy 5-1 mariners here in the
second
center fielder michael a taylor two and
two
swag struck him outfit strikeout for
logan gilbert went away in the fourth
third baseman emmanuel rivera lined out
to henniger and right
into the way swinging it's popped off
shallow right center field toro out over
haniger and kelnett celtic calling for
it jared is there and he makes the easy
catch
so two outs for kansas city here in the
top of the fourth inning logan gilbert
who had been throwing the ball well in
all kinds of trouble right now the bases
loaded salvador perez going to be due up
35 home runs on the year one swing could
tie the game
logan gilbert deals and a swing and a
fly ball hit deep right center field and
that ball is gone
salvador perez a grand slam for a second
straight game
and he ties the game 5-5
last night was the first time in
franchise history they had a grand slam
in consecutive games and
salvi writes another chapter
267 against him 38 in the third 41
strikeouts the stretch out of the pitch
benetini is swinging a fly ball straight
away center kelly coming in dives and he
makes the catch
jared keldic
came in
diving and he makes an outstanding catch
robbing andrew ben and tendy and there's
one away for the royals here on the top
of the fifth inning and what a catch by
jared kelden two outs and three
successive hits of trouble
trying to put him away here oh two
swung on line drive right at crawford
it's short he makes the catch and the
side is retired and now jp crawford with
two down
pitch is a fastball hit to the left side
fielded by nikki lopez quick toss
got him by a half step the royals get
the mariners in the corner
lopez salvador perez and carlos santana
two three
four here in the sixth
dribbler treble
[Applause]
what a play he did get him
manning gonzalez right there on top of
it
first base empire another bang bang
plays pitched a scoreless inning last
night with two strikeouts
swinging a high fly ball into right
field playable henniger comes in it's
toro drifting out the mariner's second
baseman is
unable to make oh he made the catch he
lost it it popped in the air like a
snowball and then he made the catch
again
as toro fell to his backside he caught
it twice
there is out number one
he had it and then reaching back to his
left went down he added in the webbing
did snow cone of the web into his glove
when the glove hit the ground the ball
popped straight up in the air from the
seat of his pants he caught it again and
then he pops the ball to hannigar
whose second rider takes over fourth man
out of the pen he's got michael a taylor
emmanuel rivera and winton maryfield
save hard dylan moore backs up a step
for two
[Applause]
dylan moore backing up
on the track he is there to make the
catch
no advance by the run or two out take a
look at the biggest threat for the
royals salvador perez runners on it
first and third two ounce top of the
eighth game tied at five five and the
pitch on the way swinging a fly ball
into center field celtic backing up he
is there jared waits he makes the catch
paul seawall retires the side getting
the most dangerous pet in this kansas
city lineup extra innings in seattle
dozier gets to third base
and olivares gets one in the air to
center field and kellnick is trying to
get behind it dozier will tag and
kelnick heaves it all the way to the
plate but it is not in time and edward
olivares
puts the royals in front for the first
time
since the top of the first inning for
the mariners with two on and nobody out
of the winning run at first
kill one high fly ball
deep left field
ben intended he's there seeger can walk
home tie ball game luis terrence getting
it done his fourth rbi tonight olivares
put the royals in front with a sac fly
in the tent a chance to put the royals
in front again
and olivares hits it to left field
that's deep fraley is back and
he just
edward olivares
it's a two out two-strike home run in
the 12th inning shocked the house
they're at first and second with two
down and here's the rookie
jared kelnig
fastball got him
what a night